Moi je suis candidat
du Rassemblement National
qui est aujourd'hui
donné en tête des ces élections européennes
et probable, en tout cas potentiel gagnant
parmi les potentiels vainqueurs
de la prochaine élection présente.
Mais est-ce que la candidature de Marion maréchal ne
risque pas
finalement de vous faire perdre cette 1ère place ?
Ah, c'est 1 risque
est 1 risque qui est pris par le mouvement reconquête.
Je comprends pas la plus-value de cette candidature.
pense que tout le
monde est d'accord pour dire aujourd'hui
que nous pouvons gagner
non seulement ces élections européennes
mais aussi la prochaine élection présidentielle.
Donc la question que je pose c'est, est-ce que
Éric Zemmour et Marion maréchal ne devraient pas,
plutôt que de se présenter contre nous,
venir aider les patriotes à gagner les prochaines ?
Vous accepteriez intitulé
Marion Maréchal ?
Euh, Jordan Bardella,
elle a fait savoir qu'elle était candidate
3, 4 jours après que j'ai annoncé ma ma candidature.
Mais je pense qu'à l'heure où les français souffrent,
à l'heure où notre identité est menacée,
attaquée partout dans notre pays,
se présenter aux élections pour faire 5 ou 6%
alors que le principal mouvement d'opposition
est en capacité
de remporter les 2 prochaines élections,
je pense que c'est totalement contre-productif.